when you read your students stories can
you tell when a writer is avoiding their
truth well the Arrogant answer to that
is yes because it means that I know
their truth in some way that they don't
um so I try not to take the Arrogant
approach I try to take the approach of
well I don't really know what this
person's truth is but they don't quite
seem to be hitting all the notes one
thing I sometimes tell my students
is use the whole instrument which is a
musical reference essentially don't keep
playing the same few notes over and over
and over like try to use different parts
of the instrument try to create
different sounds try to do different
things and you'll arrive
at these complex truths some of which
you may be
avoiding if you do that um I'm very
reluctant to ever think I
know what's best for a student's story
and that's another thing that's sort of
not permitted in my classes
like I I don't I and nobody in my class
will say no nobody including me will say
like what you should do writer is X like
those kinds of sentences don't come out
in my classes what I say is when you
wrote this this was my reaction because
it's it's it's not saying like you need
to fix this because I don't know what
it's not my story it's like if you
decide that needs to be fixed okay but
my way of seeing things is I was
confused by this this was not clear to
me like I thought thought that this was
going to be about X but you're telling
me it's about y like that doesn't seem
to work for me like if if the reader can
really articulate in a you know in a way
that that in some way addresses what the
writer is doing then the writer can say
okay I hear what the reader's saying
maybe I should reconsider this part of
my story
so so your your question is
do I sometimes think I know these things
yes because I've been teaching for a
very long time and so I often think that
I know what might be a way to improve a
story
but I won't say it out loud and for the
most
part I just don't I don't let myself
think that way if that makes sense how
do you spot bad writing on a sentence by
sentence
basis um it it's it's it's not good well
I mean let's just start we'll start and
end with cliche
um a lot of times people use cliches in
their writing
because they don't actually want to take
the time to think of what they really
want to say this is why people use
cliches in real life um it's to avoid
thinking your own actual thoughts and I
think
that's that's one culprit that comes up
sometimes is like the person isn't
really doing the hard work of imagining
a story it's very hard it's hard to
write a short story it's hard to write
fiction like um even if you have like
some talent for it like talent's not the
only issue it's like how are you going
to write a story that's like that's
individual to you that's your way of
seeing the world and nobody else's well
if you're using
cliches you're not going to be able to
do that you're not going to be telling
your own story when I say your own story
I don't mean autobiography I mean a
story that in some
way represents your way of looking at
the world you can't do that if you're
using unoriginal language I mean short
stories are nothing if not language
that's all they are they're just a lot
of
sentences
so I mean if you're not even trying to
use original thought but are relying on
canned
language I mean that's that's not going
to work it's not going to work for me
what author or book made you fall in
love with
reading well I mean the stories that
made me want to write stories without
question were Carver's stories um I
first read Carver in '87 so he was still
alive and I just thought I mean there
was everybody else and him to me I just
I I read all of his stories multiple
times I just thought he had a way of
seeing the world seeing America the way
he used
language I mean he just was a truth
teller to me like the the truths that
were embodied in his stories not
explicitly explained but embodied in
them they just spoke to me very directly
I felt like he dealt with
um domestic violence he dealt with um he
dealt with marriage and divorce he he he
dealt
with you know um oh God that's like an
entire other interview but um he was he
he just made me think this was all I
really wanted to do from now on like the
he he it his work had such a power over
me like and there were many many other
people that this was true for I mean at
that time he was sort of already thought
of as in many ways the preeminent living
American short story writer
and um I mean I could I still remember
his stories coming out of the New Yorker
I mean the excitement of finding a new
one and then I got to see him read at
Beyond Baroque and uh I just I was like
this
guy's I love I love I love the these
stories yeah you know they say never
meet your Heroes yeah you know I made
that choice he um I remember he read
with um Tess Gallagher and she read
first and then there was a break and he
there was like a lobby area and he was
sort of standing by himself in the lobby
area in the lobby area smoking a
cigarette and he was kind of tall a
little bit hunched over
and
um he he he just was he he was sort of a
very modest seeming person and there was
like a part of me and and I was there by
myself and there was a part of me that
just wanted to say go up to him and be
like gee I just think you're the
greatest or you know whatever but I was
like there's nothing I could possibly
say to him that would in any way convey
say how I actually felt there was that
and then there was nothing he could say
that would in any way be able to satisfy
all that I would hope to hear from him
and so I I remember just sort of
standing near where he was standing and
just looking at him
like he's doing it like he he's he's
doing it
and you know I I'm glad I never talked
to him I mean I'm I I'm glad that my one
experience in his presence was just awe
and I have that awe today I still think
he's phenomenal and then when you heard
that he passed away yeah I read it in
the newspaper like everybody else um and
I was I you know I felt like I had lost
a
friend um I remember I went to an event
that Tess Gallagher gave and I asked
her if he
was sick at the time that he gave that
reading because he died not that long
after that reading and he had lung
cancer and lung cancer you know takes a
lot of people pretty quickly so but I
didn't know how long and she said no
actually not at all he didn't he didn't
know he was sick at that time
um he got sick later so
um so
yeah I I was I suffered I I was really I
just thought God the world has just lost
something so great and I can't believe
they're not going to be any more of his
stories
yeah